le tout premier trailer de cianci vient
de sortir et je suis plutôt agréablement
surpris pour rappel à la base prévue
début juillet shang chi et la légende
des dix anneaux a été repoussée pour le
3 septembre 2021
c'est un héros dont je me suis pas mal
questionné par rapport à l'avenir de
marvel car effectivement on commence à
se tourner vers quelque chose de plus en
plus cosmique et à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
on n'a jamais eu autant de super héros
aussi puissant je pense bien évidemment
à oujda maxime of captain marvel à tort
a doctor strange à et caetera et ces
mêmes pour des héros qui sont considérés
comme un peu plus lambda on va dire eh
bien ils ont toujours une différence qui
fait qu' ils sont primordiaux c'est le
cas de captain america par exemple qui
dans certains films est assez en dessous
de ses camarades on peut le dire mais
son sérum de super soldat est
aujourd'hui la possibilité d'utiliser le
marteau de thor fait qu'il est quand
même bien stylé et bien bien puissant
sans oublier évidemment tout son côté
leader du groupe des avengers du coup
c'est là que je m'interrogeais à quel
point chan chee peut devenir primordial
et principal pour la suite des
événements eh bien écoutez je vous
propose qu'on essaye d'y répondre
ensemble avec le tout nouveau trailer
qui vient de sortir et l'analyser donc
voilà qu'est ce qu'on peut en tirer par
rapport à l'histoire de cianci et son
avenir dans la même cellule
tout d'abord premières choses très
importantes à dire c'est que chan chee
est le fils de wayne ou soit le mandarin
c'est peut-être idiot dit comme ça mais
cela pose clairement les bases sur
l'origine story de notre héros dans son
histoire personnelle et via les comics
shanxi a été élevé à la dure par son
père afin de devenir son digne
successeur
et on peut le dire une véritable arme
vivante
c'est quelque chose que l'on retrouve
dans le trailer dans la production
toute la vie de change qui s'est résumée
à se former à savoir se battre et à
marcher dans l'ombre de son père pour un
jour devenir
guerrier roi suprême de l'organisation
des dix anneaux sauf que l'organisation
des dix anneaux n'est clairement pas
bienveillante c'est une organisation qui
est contre la paix et par rapport au
film d' iron man ou bien le teaser qui
démontre une passation de pouvoir de
père à fils on comprend que pour le mcs
est une organisation qui cherche à
maintenir son rang
que ce soit en terme de puissance
d'armes et de savoir d'où l'intérêt de
l'organisation pour stark industries ou
bien en bim mais également un délire de
tron à ne pas perdre
avec tout ce délire de succession entre
le mandarin et chant shin chan chee
étant le héros est un potentiel futur
nouveau avenger et bien il va évidemment
se rendre compte de tout le problème lié
à l'organisation et qu'en plus de ça
c'est dirigé par son père donc
évidemment on pouvait s'en douter et le
trailer nous le montre chan chee ne va
pas reprendre le flambeau
c'est pour moi clairement ce qui va être
intéressant et poignant dans le film
tout ce délire de confrontation entre le
père et le fils mais également tout cet
aspect frankenstein avec le monstre qui
se retourne face à son créateur
évidemment tout cet aspect cette prise
de conscience sera certainement
développer durant les dix années de
pseudo liberté corazón chi dix années où
il tentera d'avoir une vie pseudo normal
tombera amoureux se fera des amis et
c'est ce qui va jouer un certain conflit
je pense entre le père et son fils
puisque dans la métaphore
cela va le ramollir en quelque sorte par
rapport à son rôle attendu par son père
maintenant nous devons parler plus
spécifiquement des dix anneaux c'est là
pour moi la démarcation de champion par
rapport aux autres avengers
car même si shang chi est très puissant
et considéré comme l'un avoir le
meilleur combattant du monde
eh bien il reste un simple humain est
dans un monde très terre à terre comme
celui du nc u où tout est justifié et où
la magie et lee
et à des artefacts ou une explication
scientifique extraterrestre il va
falloir créer le background pour les dix
anneaux c'est une question que je me
posais beaucoup comment serait adapté
cet artefact et cette symbolique des dix
anneaux dans les comics ce sont des ânes
aux extraterrestres qui peuvent être
portés comme des bagues et qui chacun
confère un pouvoir spécifique à son
porteur le mandarin va s'approprier ce
pouvoir de sorte que seul lui peut
l'utiliser dans le teaser cela semble
respecter ce qui avait été instauré les
anneaux sont portés par le père de
champion au niveau des avants bras à la
manière du film black panthères nous
allons très certainement faire face à
une explication sur l'arrivée des dix
anneaux sur terre avec tout ce côté
traditionnel donc comme l'arrivée de la
météorite du vibranium au wac en dha et
tout ce qui s'ensuit
étant une origin story et dans l'univers
de marvel où tous les films sont reliés
nous pourrions en apprendre plus sur
comment le mandarin a fait la découverte
de ces anneaux étant au nombre de dix il
est possible que ces derniers est
étaient éparpillés à travers le monde ce
qui expliquerait pourquoi l'organisation
des dix anneaux est présente dans chaque
recoin de la planète
cependant par rapport à iron man 1 où
l'organisation des dix anneaux existe
déjà et comme le démontre leur logo ou
les anneaux sont au nombre de dix
on peut supposer que le mandarin possède
les anneaux depuis déjà un paquet
d'années
donc cela sous-entend que la présence
d'un flash back au début du film est
envisageable
d'ailleurs ces anneaux apportant un
certain pouvoir dits magiques en quelque
sorte sous entend clairement qu'ils sont
d'origine extraterrestre ou du moins
qu'ils sont au delà des connaissances
humaines car dans une cohérence même si
l'organisation des dix anneaux semble
être très intéressé par les armes et la
technologie et bien des grands savants
et ingénieurs comme tony stark ou hank
pym n'ont jamais pu produire de telles
choses on parle de pouvoirs liés aux
éléments à la psy chic et à une force
décuplée
donc voilà pour moi cela appuie
clairement l'idée d'une technologie
extra terrestre et qui expliquerait du
coup pourquoi le mandarin a pu prendre
un tel contrôle sur ses ennemis et
expliquerait du coup son ascension en
groupe
enfin par rapport à la liaison avec les
autres avengers l'organisation des dix
anneaux a déjà été mêlé à plusieurs
histoires dans le mc eu
on pense évidemment à tony stark ou
encore le shield par exemple mais
j'aimerais également soulevé le cas de
hockey dans avengers endgame
effectivement on ne sait pas ce que
faisait réellement aux cayes devenu
ronin durant les cinq années du snap de
thanos nous savons simplement que ce
dernier était au mexique pour tuer des
méchants en quelque sorte et black widow
la retrouver ensuite au japon en train
de tuer à yakuza d'une organisation
criminelle
je ne m'avance sur rien mais dans une
idée de liaison entre changy et les
avengers ainsi que la série prochaine
dédié à hawk eye et kate bishop
il est possible que durant ces cinq
années aux cayes traquer des membres de
l'organisation des dix anneaux répartis
à travers le monde
et chose encore plus pertinente c'est
que les avengers connaissent entre
autres cette organisation de par
l'histoire d' ironman de possiblement
aux cailles du coup mais étant une
organisation très secrète ils n'ont
jamais vraiment pu la démanteler
tout comme hydra en quelque sorte alors
l'arrivée du fils du patron chez les
avengers pourrait totalement changer la
donne shang chi révélant tous les
secrets de l'organisation à ces nouveaux
potentiels alliés
ce qui permettrait de démanteler tout ça
pour toujours mais bon je m'avance
beaucoup pour le moment dans tous les
cas l'histoire personnelle de shang chi
est intimement liée à sa relation avec
son père qui n'est pas n'importe qui
donc il existe une très grande
possibilité qu'à la fin du film
le mandarin soit toujours en vie et puis
une telle organisation ne peut pas se
démanteler en un seul film
néanmoins chaque ci sera un héros très
puissant surtout grâce à l'utilisation
des dix anneaux de son père
car on se doute qu'il va forcément les
utiliser à un moment tels docteur
strange à la découverte de la pierre du
temps étant le mcg fine du film c'est
obligé que ces artefacts soit ceux qui
le mèneront à la victoire
écoutez je pense m'arrêter ici j'espère
que cette vidéo vous aura plu
n'oublions pas que ce teaser est avant
tout une entrée en matière et nous
aurons beaucoup plus d'informations dans
les semaines et les mois à venir
n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit
commentaire pour me dire ce que vous
avez pensé du teaser ce que vous pensez
de chang chi des dix anneaux du mandarin
et cetera a laissé un petit pouce bleus
à vous abonner à la chaîne instagram à
twitter et cetera et cetera aller
c'était argot rock et que le lionheart
soit avec vous ciao tout le monde
[Musique]